hey guys welcome back to another video
by simply learn
in today's video we're going to look at
top web developer interview questions
now web development basically involves
building and maintaining websites a web
developer is responsible for how the
website feels and functions
he is also responsible for the user
interface page layout and backend
systems
so if you wish to become a web developer
then you're in the right place this
video will give you the top interview
questions asked for web developers
but before we begin if you haven't
subscribed to our channel already make
sure to hit the subscribe button and the
bell icon to never miss an update
so here's what we'll be learning
first we look at some commonly asked
interview questions in html
moving on we'll look at some of the
commonly asked css interview questions
then javascript php and mysql so without
further ado let's begin the top 30
interview questions based on html so
html stands for hypertext markup
language it is the most widely used
language for developing web applications
it was created by berners-lee in the
year 1991 but it was published in the
year 1995. html4 was a popular
breakthrough version and got published
in the year 1991.
this version gained a lot of popularity
and was adopted all over the globe for
developing web applications so without
further ado let's get started with the
interview questions based on html it's
the first question
what is html html stands for hyper text
markup language and it is the language
of the internet it is a standard text
formatting language used for creating
and displaying pages on internet html
documents are made up of the elements
and tags that format it properly and
display it on pages
so we have our next question now
what are html tags so the answer for
this question is html tags are used for
placing the elements in a proper and
appropriate format tags use the symbols
greater than and less than to set them
apart from the html content the html
tags need not to be closed always for
example in case of images the closing
tags are not required for an image tag
now followed by the second question we
have our third question what are html
attributes the attributes are the
properties that can be added to an html
tag that change the way the tag behaves
or displayed for example an image tag
an image stack has src attribute with
which you can use the source from which
you have to display the image from
now the attributes are added right after
the name of the html tag inside the
brackets the attributes can only be
added to opening or self-closing tags
but never in closing tags
now followed by third question we have
our next question what is marquee in
html marquee is used for scrolling text
on a web page it scrolls the image or
text up down left or right automatically
to apply for a marquee you have to use
marquee tags
now we have our fifth question how do
you separate a section of text in html
we separate a section of text in html
using the below tags which are the break
tag paragraph tag and block code the
break tag is used to separate a line of
text it breaks the current line and
shifts the flow of the text line to a
new line followed by that we have the
paragraph line the paragraph line is
used to write a paragraph of text and
third one the block code the block code
tag is used to define large quoted
sections
now we have our sixth question define
the types of lists in html so we have
the three types of lists in html which
are the ordered list unordered list and
definition list so first we'll discuss
the ordered list the ordered list uses
ol tag and displays elements in a
numbered format next we have the
unordered list the unordered list uses
ul tag and displace elements in a
bulleted format thirdly we have the
definition list the definition list uses
dl dt and dd tags and displays elements
in the form of definition
like a dictionary
next we have our seventh question
how do you align list of elements in an
html file we can align the list elements
in an html file by using indents if you
indent each nested list and further than
the parent list then you can easily
align and determine the various lists
and the elements that it contains
now we have our eighth question
differentiate between ordered list and
unordered list so the answer for this
question is an unordered list uses ul
tags and each element of the list is
written between li tags the items are
displayed as bullets rather than numbers
now coming into ordered list so for
creating an ordered list you'll be using
ol tags and each element inside the list
as written using li tags the list items
are displayed using numbers rather than
bullet points now we have a sample on
the screen right now so the first three
elements are a
set of unordered lists which are
represented using bullet packs and the
second set which is the coffee tea and
milk is an ordered list which is
represented using numbers
now moving ahead we have the ninth
question how do you display a table in
html web page
so the table and html can be created or
displayed using the table tag
so it also uses to manage the layout of
the page for example header section
navigation bar body content photo
section etc etc so given below are a
list of html tags used for displaying
table in an html webpage so we have
table tr th et cetera et cetera table is
used to define a table tr is used to
define a row in a table th for header td
for a cell caption is used to define a
caption and we have the call group which
is used to specify a group of one or
more columns in a table for formatting
next we have call which is used with
call group element to specify column
properties for each column next we have
t body which is used to group the body
content in a table next we have t head t
footer which are used for header content
and footer content respectively moving
forward we have our 10th question
how do you display the given table in an
html webpage so the answer for this
question is written on the right side
part of my screen this is the sample
code which you can use to represent or
display a table which is given in this
particular format over here now followed
by this we have our 11th question how do
we insert a comment in html so the
answer for this question is
we can insert a comment in html by
beginning with lesser than sign and
ending with a greater than sign for
example as shown in the right side part
of my screen which is hello world now
moving ahead we have our 12th question
how do you insert a copyright symbol in
html so you can insert a copyright
symbol by using ampersand copy semicolon
or
ampersand
169 semicolon in an html file now moving
ahead we have our 13th question so what
is a white space in html so the answer
for this question is an empty sequence
of space characters is called as white
space in html this white space is
considered as a single space character
in html white space helps the browser to
merge multiple spaces into one single
space and so taking care of indentation
becomes easier
whitespace helps in better organizing
the content and tags making them
readable and easy to understand
with this let's move into the 14th
question
how do you create links in different
sections within the same html web page
so the answer is anchor tags we can use
anc attack along with referencing
through the use of hashtag symbol to
create several links to different
sections within the same web page moving
ahead we have the 15th question how do
you create a hyperlink in html so the
answer is we can use anchor tag again
here the same thing we can use anchor
tag to create a hyperlink within the
html that links to another web page the
hyperlink can be added to images too now
moving ahead into our sixteenth question
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
define an image map so the answer for
this question is an image map in html
helps in linking with the different
kinds of web pages using the single
image it can be used for defining spaces
in the images that are made part of the
image mapping process
moving ahead we have our 17th question
why do we use stylesheet in html a
stylesheet helps in creating a
well-defined template for html web page
that is both consistent as well as
portable a single style sheet template
can be linked to various web pages which
makes it easier to maintain and change
the look of the website now the 18th
question what is semantic in html
so the answer for this question is
semantic html is a coding style it is
the use of html markup to reinforce the
semantics or the meaning of the content
for example the semantic html b tag is
not used for bold statement as well as i
tag which is not used for italic instead
we use strong and em tags
now followed by the 18 question we have
our 19th question
what is svg in html so the html svg is
used to describe the vector or raster
graphics svg images and their behaviors
are defined in xml text sheets it is
mostly used for vector type diagrams
like pie charts two dimensional graphs
in an x y coordinate system now moving
ahead we have our 20th question what
would happen if there is no text between
the html tags so the answer for this
question is really simple there would be
nothing to format if there is no text
present in between the tags therefore
nothing will appear on the screen some
tags such as the tags without closing
tag like image tag do not require any
text between them
now followed by the 20th question we
have our next question how do you create
nested web pages in an html so nested
web pages basically mean a web page
within a web page we can create nested
web pages in html using the built-in
iframe tag the html live frame tag
defines an inline frame for example
which is displayed on the right side
part of my screen you can see the iframe
source
which redirects the user to simply
learn's official web page
now followed by that we have our 22nd
question how do you add buttons in html
so we can use the built-in button tag in
html to add buttons to the html web page
so on the right hand part of my screen
you can see the implementation of button
to an html web page now followed by 20
second question we have our 23rd
question
what are the different types of headings
in html so the answer for this question
is there are basically six types of
heading tags in html which are defined
with h1 to h6 stacks
each type of the heading tag displays
different text size from another
where h1 is being the largest and h6 is
being the smallest so on the right hand
part of my screen you can see the
implementation of heading tags from h1
to h6 now the
output for this particular code segment
is the h1 h2 s3 h4 h5 h6 so you can see
that h1 is being the biggest one and h6
is being the smallest one now moving
ahead into our 24th question how do you
insert an image in the html web page so
the answer for this question is you can
insert an image in the html webpage by
using the following code which is
displayed on the right side part of my
screen you can see we have a image
source is equals to tulip.jpeg
which is used for inserting an image
into your html webpage
now our 25th question what is the alt
attribute in html now the answer for
this question is the alt attribute is
used for displaying the text in place of
an image whenever the image cannot be
loaded due to any technical issue
so basically when you have poor internet
connection and you're trying to load an
image you can see some sort of text in
place of an image so that particular
text is nothing but the art attribute
now moving ahead we have our 26th
question how are hyperlinks inserted in
the html webpage you can insert a
hyperlink in the html webpage by using
the following code which is present on
the right side part of my screen
you can use the anchor tag along with
hedge reference and inside that
particular tag you can use the url to
which you want your users to redirect to
now followed by this we have our 27th
question how do you add color to the
text in html
so the answer for this question is you
can add color to the text by using the
following code which is present on the
right side part of my screen where you
can add a red color and blue color green
color to this particular paragraph and
headings now followed by 27th question
we have our 28th question
how do you add css styling in html so
there are three particular ways to add
css to your html there are inline css
external style sheet and internal style
sheet we'll discuss each of these
methods in a bit more detail first we
have the inline css
so it is used when less amount of
styling is needed or in cases where only
a single element has to be styled to use
inline styles add the style attribute in
the relevant tag now moving ahead we
have the external style sheet this is
used when the style is applied to many
elements or html pages each page must
link to the style sheet using the link
tag
now we have the last one which is the
internal style sheet it is used when a
single html document has a unique style
and several elements need to be styled
to follow the format
internal style sheet is added in the
head section of the html page by
style tag now followed by this we have
our 29th question
what hierarchy do the style sheets
follow
the answer for this question is if a
single selector includes three different
style definitions the definition that is
closest to the actual tag takes
precedence inline style takes priority
over embedded style sheets which takes
priority over external style sheets now
our last question for the session today
how do you add javascript to an html web
page so the answer for this question is
we basically have three methods to add a
javascript to our html webpage they are
inline script block and
external javascript file first we'll
discuss the inline
you can add javascript to your html
elements directly whenever a certain
event occurs javascript code can be
added using attributes of the html tags
that support it now the next one that is
the script block you can define a script
block anywhere inside the html code
which will get executed as soon as the
browser reaches to that part of the
document this is why script blocks are
usually added at the end part of the
html documents now the last one that is
the external javascript file you can
also add or import the javascript code
from a separate file and keep your html
code clutter free this is especially
useful if there is a large amount of
scripting added to the html webpage css
interview questions
as we know it very well today in a
current scenario
you being as a front-end developer css
playing a very very important role so in
interview what kind of questions are
asked and what kind of answers we have
to give let's talk about those
okay
so let's get started with those
questions and answers
okay
now
here
we'll talk about basic css interview
questions
now name some css frameworks as we know
it very well today in css environment
there's so many frameworks are available
okay like
we talk about css these are basically
necessary libraries which offers you
some very popular ready-made components
which you can utilize into your
existing project and without writing
much code you can really create some
awesome effects so
some of the very very popular libraries
are like in foundation
bootstrap
gumby ukit semantic ui
and many more which are available here
okay
now what do you understand by the
universal selector see universal
selector as you know it very well in css
normally we talk about specific
selectors like in talk about class
selectors id selectors
they select a specific set of elements
or specific element
when we talk about universal selectors
universe selector is matches any element
types like instead of selecting elements
of a particular type so you talk about
like an asterisk where all elements
irrespective of what name and what
category they have it all will be
selected
next
tell us about
rule set see typically rule set is
for the identification for selector
which can be attached with
other selectors so there are normally
two rule sets are available
when we talk about declaration block and
we talk about selector
so declaration block contains one or
more semicolons separated by
declarations
set of styles which we say and the
selector is means or which particular
element this css style will be
intended for
next
what are the elements of css box model
okay so we know it very well the csx box
model is all about offering you the
layout which is a part of the design
element so in css we can see this
elements are like an images you talk
about text okay you talk about padding
which is so called
area around the content you talk about
border talk about margin
okay so you talk about this cs6 box
model
next
difference between css3 and css2 we know
it very well css has changed a lot and
css3 has brought so many new features
so we talk about a difference in css2 so
c6 splits up the different sections of
code into the modules so in css3 both
css and html were put into the single
file
in css3 there were no new way of writing
the css rules
there are new rules are available
in writing a css rules
normally in css3 it is a backward
compatibility maintained by the css3
but in css2 we do not have any backup
compatibility maintained by the css2
here
now how can css be
integrated into the html page
like in order to utilize this we always
use the style sheet we use style tag
okay so multiple options are available
when we talk about using the style tag
in a head section
else we talk about inline styling with
an element itself or third we talk about
external style sheet which you can link
it with your current html page which
anyways enforce reusability
coming back what is the rgb stream
so rgb stands for red green and blue so
it represents a color in css so they are
basically
starting with the color number 0 goes
till 256.
next
what is the purpose of developing a css
okay the main purpose of developing a
css to basically offer the visual
appearance to give the better look and
feel to your code so that your html will
offer only the skeleton part but when it
comes to the beautification
you talk about organization and
everything you talk about the css
okay so css offers the styling part of
your web page which looks more
attractive
so what is the difference between class
and id see these are two different type
of selectors are available in css
class selectors and id selectors
so class is the way of using these html
elements
so they are not unique and have multiple
elements
where the id is unique and it can be
assigned to a single element
so with css different documents can be
controlled using the single style so
style can be grouped in a complex
situation
to offer the consistent
look for the multiple html pages
so that is what the advantage is you
have it
so you can group multiple styles
together and that you can reuse over the
different pages to offer the consistent
styling
okay
now we talk about some intermediate css
interview questions
so here in the intermediate level you
will see
like the first question is like what
define a z index see zen index is
specify the stack order of the elements
that overlap each other
okay so its default value is zero and
can take both negative and positive
values
okay
the higher the z index value is stacked
above the lower index element so it
normally takes the following value
talk about like an auto number initial
and inherit
next
you talk about what are the benefits of
css sprites see the main benefit of css
sprite is
like loading a multiple image is not
an issue
okay
uh blinking is not seen there's some
advantages are available like when you
talk about like
at one single or small small images
it really takes a lot of time to
download it individually so css sprites
loading multiple image is not an issue
blinking is not seen
because normally what happens blinking
happens when the image is getting loaded
so advanced downloading of asset doesn't
make a place off
until needed that's the benefit of
having the css sprites
next how can you target the h3 and h2
with the same styling so you can do the
comma separated so you can see multiple
elements can be targeted with using
comma separated so you use comma
separated values to give the consistent
style to both the elements
so name and media types allowed by css
so media types are basically a part of
your responsiveness
different media types are allowed like
in speech audio visual tactile media
continuous or page media grip media or
bitmap or interactive media
these are all type of medias
are allowed in css
so how can you use
css to control image repetition so we
talk about no repeat so background
repeat properties which is available so
you can see
background repeat none so that it would
not be repeated again and again within
your background
okay so we're talking about the next
questions like
about the image scrolling control how
you can
control the image scrolling so that you
want the image to be remain fixed
and rest of the part gets scrolled
so here it is a part of your background
attachment property
so here you say the background repeat no
repeat and you see background attachment
fixed so that when you scroll down your
image is not going to be scrolled
so that is the benefit of this image
control scrolling
now
name some font related css attributes
we have some options available like you
talk about font style weight
variance size
family these are the
font related css attributes
define contextual selector
so normally in css the context
contextual selectors allows developer to
specify style
of a different part of the document
okay so style which you utilize it can
be aligned directly to the static html
pages
to create independent classes
okay that's called contextual selector
so responsive web design responsive web
design is a web design which you want to
remain consistent
across multiple device screens or the
different type of screen sizes
and you want to offer the better layout
which doesn't looks bloated over the
different websites
so that's the benefit which you see when
you talk about like responsive web
design
css
nomenclature
css nomenclature means the styling
commands are written in a value on a
property fashion
okay so normally css includes a system
terminator semicolon the entire style is
wrapped in a curly braces and attached
to the dedicated selector
okay so this actually creates a style
sheet that can be applied to an html
page so this is the standard
nomenclature
okay
now coming back to the next point
advanced css interviews
i will tell you about few questions
which are normally asked as a part of
advanced css
okay
now when do you use translate instead of
absolute positioning okay so the
translate in a css
okay transform value on changing
you can talk about opacity or transform
okay so the browser reflow or repaint is
not triggered
when we talk about this translate
okay so the transform requires a browser
to create a gpu layer for
elements
okay but using the cpu changes
absolute positioning property so
translate is more efficient and result
in
shorter paint times
next name different ways to position
same aspects in css
okay
so you talk about positioning properties
okay
so there are five different positions
values are number one you talk about
fixed you talk about static
you have absolute you have got relative
and never got sticky so five different
positioning elements are available in
css
what are mixens
mixens is a similar to the function
block of code returning a single value
it is a kind of function which we say
okay
so traditionally it is used in a sas or
okay which is typically called
statically awesome style sheet so
that code that directly compiles into
the css styles
so how can you optimize the web page for
the prints so
you actually identify a control
okay so called contents areas of a
website
a general website has a footer header
sidebar or nav bar
or content area
so
normally we say conquer the print pdf
without changing the website's integrity
by using the page breaks so creating
styles for print
size
your page for print and avoid
unnecessary html tables so using this
you can optimize the print of your web
pages
so what is the meant by css working
under the hood so when you browser
display a document it actually combines
the style
okay which presents information and
document content so the document is
actually processed in two stages number
one
conversation
okay or conversion of html and css into
the document object model so called dom
and dom display contents of browser
different between the use of id selector
and class selector we have already seen
that but this is a simple demo of how
the id selector in class selectors are
used the difference is all about using
so here you have a call id which use
dot sorry this hash and there you use
dot
so tell us about css float property so
normally css float properties
uh of positioning an image to the right
or left as needed so it typically
including text wrapping around it so all
properties of elements used before it
remain unchanged that is known as called
float
so what do you understand with the
pseudo elements so pseudo elements are
special effects to your selectors so
normally css finds
okay using applying styles in a html
markup so if additional markup or style
is not visible for a document then
pseudoelements help by allowing extra
markup without
interfering with the original
document
difference between
logical and physical tag so normally
logical tags focus on the content
okay
and are older as compared to the
physical ones
logical ones do not find much usage in
presentation in terms of
utilization
at the same time physical ones find
application in presentations
how media type works in css type so we
have discussed already about a media
type
so we normally say four different type
of media properties are available i can
print speech and screens
okay like you talk about
print media screen so we use always add
the rate media print you talk about h2
so this changes according to what option
you're offering it
so guys here we have multiple css
question and frequently our css
interview questions are offered like
tell
something about css3
okay so we say css is divided into the
modules and is supported by almost every
single browser
okay it is an advanced version of css2
and offering you lot many other advanced
level features which typically in css2
we do not have that
okay
now
we talk about how css selectors used
so with the css selectors we can choose
you know any element of your html
okay so
you talk about element attribute you
talk about any child selector you can
basically select it
so what are css image scripts
so the group of image placed into the
one single image is in a css image
script it can reduce the load time
because individual images certainly take
more time so this takes more time
comparatively
so we have a god explain css
a specificity
so the css specificity is a rank or
score that decides style declarations to
be used to an element
id selectors have high specificity while
universal selector has low specificity
that's how the specificity is all about
so the four css categories that
authorize the selectors specificity
levels are ids inline element pseudo and
class and style attributes so these are
the different type of conditions based
on that the specificity is considered
defined gradients in css we know the
gradient
are
again a css3 property that allows
displaying the smooth transformation
from one type of color to another color
okay
so that's really awesome technique
through which you can talk about linear
gradient or else you talk about radian
gradients but two different type of
gradients are
used and supported
so what are the properties of flexbox so
we know flexbox are basically designed
for the alignment purpose
so typical the flex boxes are flex
direction you talk about wrap flow
content align items and the contents
like that it is once again the property
of alignment
so tell us about the usage of css box
model so normally blocks box model is a
box binding in html elements that
includes padding border margin and the
actual content for the more better
alignment
so normally the box model you get an
authority to add a border all around the
elements and define space between the
elements
so what are the position
states in css so we normally talk about
four positions in css so called relative
statics absolute and fixed
the default position is status always
static
so different between absolute and
relative in css
so normally relative is useful for some
tags in css if we write like 20 pixels
then padding shift 20 pixels in a right
but when we talk about absolute
so it is
absolute is relevant relative to the
non-static pattern that means if i'm
talking about
if we say right 20 pixels the result
will be 20 pixels far from the right
edge of the parent element that's how
the relative and absolute position is
so what is the common between class and
id see both class are id used in html
okay for the css purpose the id is used
as an element where the class is used as
a block
so this particular information is all
about giving you the idea of like what
kind of questions
it may be asked during the time of
interview which is related to your
javascript so
this particular slides will help you to
understand what kind of questions
you may expect
from your interviewer and kind of
answers you need to get ready with
let's get started with the javascript
interview questions
so let's get started with the beginner
javascript questions we have multiple
levels available here we start with the
beginner level first
so the first question is always like
what do you understand about javascript
so we know it very well the javascript
is a very very popular scripting
language it is basically designed for
client-side scripting
and server-side scripting development
why server side because nowadays
javascript is also used in a backend
using node.js so that's why it is also
called for server side development so
the question is like
uh javascript is
actually also helps the developers to
develop some more responsive html pages
okay which can be well understood and
executed by the web browser
okay which having the support
capabilities for object-oriented
programming skills
now
the next question is like what is the
difference between javascript and java
see the reason is because the javascript
initials are java so everybody think
like okay there is some relationship
with the java so actually the thing is
like there is no relationship with java
i would say javascript is object based
language
whether java is object oriented language
a lot of syntax
and some standards are matching with
java that's why exactly it is saying it
is javascript
otherwise there is nothing like that
but another difference if i talk about
javascript is mainly designed to run
with the browsers where the java is
designed especially for the virtual
machine and operating system
now another thing is like javascript
does not need a compilation because it
is directly used interpreter but when
you talk about java it requires a
compiler as well as the interpreter both
now
what type of various data types are
supported so all standard
data types i can buy short int long
float double character boolean
these all different type of data types
are supported in
javascript also just like in traditional
programming languages
okay
now
what are the features of javascript so
the first feature which you always
remember it's it is a lightweight
programming language it has
been interpreted by
the browsers rather than compiled
it is a cross platform that means it can
work across multiple browsers so it is
not specific to the browsers
so that we need to understand
next it is an open source hence you do
not need to pay for any licensing fees
it comes free with all different type of
browsers
it is an object oriented but i would not
say it as a pure object oriented i would
rather say it is an object based
language
next it can gel well with multiple front
end as well as the back-end technologies
because most of the languages which are
coming up in a market they have a
support available to get integrated with
the javascript and due to that
javascript is very very popular
so it is also used especially for the
development like a network-based
application
so in case if you want to have some kind
of network-centric application here the
javascript really suits very very well
okay
next question what are the advantages of
javascript so the first
advantage which we are talking about
like javascript basically have a very
very nice interactive language it is a
event-based
okay functional programming language i
would say so it is a quick feedback
because it loads very very fast
in your existing web pages
it is
giving you the support of developing a
very very rich
user interface because of that your
application look consistent across
multiple type of browsers
[Music]
another is like we have a call variety
of javascript based frameworks are
available
like you can talk about
angular you talk about react you talk
about vue they're all basically
different type of javascript based
frameworks that helps the developer to
enhance their skills
with writing less amount of codes
so how you create a script or how you
create an object in javascript it is
very simple the curly braces
curly braces is basically designed to
give you the feel of this is a typical
object there are variety of ways are
there to create an object in javascript
which we're going to see uh in our next
video
okay
now here we see about the next set of
questions which are there with us
like how to create an array in
javascript so creating an arrays in
javascript is very very easy now you can
see the square brackets
okay they are the way to basically
create an
array in the javascript so just a square
brackets are a very very simpler way so
called laterals to create
the array objects
in javascript actually you should know
that array is also object which is a
predefined object comes with your
javascript so called implicit objects
now what are the built-in methods
available in javascript so you remember
about these methods comes from those
built-in objects comes with your
javascript as we have mentioned in our
last slides like math
boolean
string
okay
date they're all basically predefined
objects are available under those
objects these methods are actually
available like date if you can see it
will display the current date and time
concat to concat two different type of
string push some
adding some new records into your array
pop to remove
around to do the round
length to calculate the length of the
string so these are all some well-known
methods or frequently used methods
available in javascript
now what different type of scopes
available in javascript for the
variables now
so scopes are basically designed to give
you the visibility
with the new program
okay so different type of scopes are
available when it's called a global
scope so global scope is having the
availability within a file
anywhere else you can access this
particular code or particular variable
this is called global scope and local
scopes are those scopes which are
accessible within a function
and hence cannot be accessed by any
other function or outside of this
function so two standard type of scopes
which are available here
now what is this keyword in javascript
this means to refer the current object
okay so whenever you see that this
keyword it is designed to refer the
current object in
javascript so we typically define that
this keyword to assign the value to my
current object properties
usually this is the place where that
this keyword is mostly used
now what are the conventions of
giving the names to the variables
okay so some standard naming convention
which we should always follow
but few things as you remember there are
certain reserve keywords
are there in javascript which you cannot
offer
while giving the names to your variables
or to your functions
like if i can say
let const and many more which are there
available which you cannot assign to
your any existing variable
provided or functions
under your javascript
now
here they are trying to say
variable names cannot begin with any
numeric value like you cannot give
var with abc so not abc i would say
rather one two three or something like
that so they must be a combination of
i would say integer as well as a
character
okay so
they must only begin with letter or
underscore characters it is the same
like as we have it in java also
now naming conventions are very very
important
javascript is a case sensitive hence
the small a and capital a have two
different meanings for the javascript so
that part needs to be well taken care of
now what is the callback in javascript
so you need to understand the callback
in javascript is a kind of function
which you are passing as in parameter to
the other function to execute
okay so callbacks are mainly designed
to
tell your application that
they need to wait rather than continue
to execute
so callbacks will help you to behave
asynchronously and that's what exactly
this most
valuable feature of javascript
so as i discussed already so it is where
the function needs to be passed to get
executed
so how do you debug a javascript code so
to debug your javascript code in any
browser you can just press the f12
no matter which browser you have it
either chrome
or firefox or anyone can just press the
f12 key and there
you can get this option called debugger
where you can just go and perform all
the necessary debugging related stuff
right over there
or
so many other editors like in sublime
text visual studio code
atom they're all offering you the
built-in support to debug your
javascript code
now what is the difference between a
function declaration and function
expression so this is a very very simple
difference
so when you say
function abc here
okay so you declare as a separate
statement within the same javascript
code
okay in another example what you do you
define a function within a variable name
called a
which you can create to construct some
another object for this
that's the only difference between these
two
so
this function
can be called before the function is
defined
and this will be created where the
function is pointing
and reaching it
okay so it can be used only after that
so that's what we have discussed it now
going forward
this offers the better code readability
and better code organization and that
the other part is basically used to
create a conditional or declaration
functions
so what are the ways of adding the
javascript code in an html file so they
are
i would say
two ways are available
one
either you can declare it in a separate
file you can add it or second you can
write a embedded javascript code where
you can just write a javascript code
either in your head tag or body tag but
there'll be one difference like if
you're writing it as an embedded
javascript you cannot use it
for the different html file where the
internal javascript file will be limited
to that html however external javascript
will be more useful when you want to
reuse it again and again
so these were some
standard
basic javascript questions for us so
let's go ahead and talk about something
which is related to your intermediate
questions in javascript
now so what do you understand about the
cookies see the cookies are basically a
kind of a small text file okay which is
kept in your browser
and contains the information
about your client activities
okay so whenever the client is accessing
your websites
these websites
can track your activities through these
particular cookies
okay so this just basically record
your general
behaviors like what you're doing with
your website so that accordingly they
can give you
the better recommendations
now how you're gonna create a cookie in
your javascript so creating a cookie
cookie is one of the property available
under your document object so that you
can create it using document.cookie
and give a key so
your all cookies are stands with your
key and value pair so you have a key you
have a value pair
so how you gonna read the cookie
so cookie you can read with the help of
the same property called document.cookie
and here you can just use this statement
like what key in value pair so whatever
the keys you have defined
similar q will be reading it to give the
value of whatever
option you want to read it
now how are you gonna delete the cookie
so
cookie can be deleted it very easily by
calling this delete cookie function
where you can just tell about
the time and duration when you want the
cookie to be get deleted
so when you set the expiry time so
cookies are deleted
after specific period of time that will
be treated as a good programming
practice
so what is the difference between a
letter and var keyword see there's a new
feature which is there added called let
keyword which is known as called
block level scope the blockable scope
means
your variable whichever you're defining
under
any block level statement will be
limited to that particular block like if
you're defining it any opening block and
closing block
so beyond that you cannot see that
suppose if you're defining it under if
block
or any block so these
type of variables
are no longer accessible outside where
the var keyword will be typically
treated as a global variable and hence
it can be accessed
anywhere
so what is the closure in javascript so
closure is basically going to give you
a better way of
providing the consistent way of
developing a javascript code for the
developer so closures are basically
created whenever a variable that is
defined outside of this current scope
can be accessed within the current scope
okay that means which is
a variable which is defined outside the
scope even using the scope
of this particular closure it can be
accessed inside too
now
what are the arrow functions in
javascript
friends arrow function in javascript is
very very popular now they're just gonna
give you a kind of alternative way of
defining the function keyword
these are just a shortcut way of
defining the function in
javascript these are the simple handy
functions i would say
so what are the different ways of html
can be accessed in javascript course so
there are multiple ways are there so you
can access using document.getelementby
class name you can access git element by
id you can get access document get
element by tag name and you can say
document.queryselector so these are the
multiple options are
through which you can access the element
within your html tags
what are the ways of defining a variable
so var keyword as we discussed
you can define a variable you can also
define the variable using const so if
you define any variable using const so
these variables will get constantly
declared and it cannot be changed
once you define the value so any value
or any variable which is defined using
const
it cannot be changed in later stretches
what are imports and export in
javascript
so to make your javascript modular
so there's an option available of
importing and exporting it
so what exactly the difference
difference is very simple like you are
writing the set of javascript code and
if you want to get it accessed
outside in another javascript file so
how the two javascript files can
communicate with each other that is
where exactly the important export code
comes to make your javascript highly
reused and more modular
now
these are the quick example as you can
see now two different files are there so
if you want to make your particular
variable
or function accessed outside you always
use export keyword with them
and if you want to access them out you
can just use an import keyword as you
can see it is defined there
so
another file can easily access your
the content of the previous files to
make your code even more modular and
useful
so what is the difference between a
document and window in javascript see
document is the one which is a part of
your document part which user can
actually see that
okay so the document object is the
object which falls under the category of
window window is a top level object so
in javascript we have an option
available name called
bom that is called browser object model
in which the top level object which is
there that is called window and under
this we have a call document so whatever
you see
under your browser it is a part of your
document
so what are the some
javascript frameworks
and their uses see javascript frameworks
are mainly useful to make your
application more organized
with less code
and without getting into into the detail
okay so having this particular framework
will give you the opportunity so that
developer can
use the javascript in much more better
way
to write a complex code in more
simplified manner
this is where exactly
your frameworks are designed for so
there are some very prominent and useful
frameworks like in react angular
vue.js and lot many other names are
there in market
which will be using the javascript as a
core and take the entire javascript
development to the next level
so the next question is what is the
difference between
a
undefined and undeclared in javascript
see it is very simple
undefined means the variable which is
undefined
you're declaring a variable
okay and which you haven't defined
okay that means the variable has been
declared but the value has not yet
assigned that is called undefined
undeclared means the variable which
you're trying to access that itself is
not available it doesn't even exist
so what is the difference between
undefined and null in javascript see
undefine as i already told you it means
the variable has been declared but it is
not assigned with any value null is
actually the assignment value that
we can assign to any variable
which contained no values as an
alternative i would say so what is the
difference between session storage and
local storage see it is very simple
html5 has offered these features to you
so the session storage and local storage
both offers you the
data which can be stored in a browser
but session storage is short-lived
the moment your page is deleted or
closed the session data is immediately
get deleted
whether local storage data is remain for
the longer period of time and the data
doesn't get deleted after the browser
history is over
okay so i would say the local storage
time span is far bigger compared to the
session storage
okay everyone so we'll have some
advanced javascript questions now
we've already seen the beginner level
as well as the intermediate level
questions now it's time to discuss about
some advanceable questions to like
the first questions like comes like how
do you empty an array in javascript so
it is very simple
if you want to assign
so there are few ways are there number
one by assigning the array length to
what to the zero
so automatically turns to empty second
is what by assigning the completely
empty array
okay the third will be by popping up all
the elements of the array
so multiple options are there and the
last which you talk about by using the
splice function so these are the four
important aspects are there
which you can treat how to
empty your
javascript
array in a very very simplified manner
now what is the difference between even
capturing and even bubbling see this is
one of the very very common question we
talk about even capturing even capturing
is actually the kind of process
where you just try to
capture the event of
most outer most element and then
propagating it to the innermost element
so even capturing is what like you're
talking about picking up the element
or picking up the event from the
outermost like you talk about call
nested div tags so you pick up the
particular you know even from the most
outer most div tag and you're just
passing it to the innermost then it's
called capturing the bubbling is the
process
okay which starts with the innermost and
goes to the outermost elements this is
an opposite direction that is called
event bubbling
so the question is one of the very very
popular like what is the strict mode in
javascript see the stick mode of
javascript is introduced
to give the more better error handling
capacity of the javascript so whenever
we talk about call strict mode so all
variables have to be declared explicitly
so you cannot leave it like that and it
cannot be assigned to the read-only
properties
so we can enable the strict mode only by
adding the user strict mode on the top
of the javascript file
now
what about
and how we would be able to get the
following output of the below javascript
code so we have a call var equal to 10
and we have written one function in the
if block
and after that we just capturing the
value of a and then you are printing the
value in a console.log
so what would be the output for that see
it'll be
a call then undefined
once again it'll be kind of what it'll
be
undefined how come it would be look it
is very simple
first thing
okay
in your application
you are basically saying the if
condition statement in the code will
evaluate the eval function
as you know very well what exactly the
evaluation is later on the eval
function
okay will take the function and return
the function abc whatever the function
it is available
and then inside the if statement it
execute the abc and return the undefined
because as you know it variable the if
statement code execute at runtime but
the statement inside this if condition
is being evaluated so that's where
exactly it is
next can you write a javascript code for
adding the new element in a dynamic
manner yes exactly you can write it down
so you have this very common function
available name called
document.createelement
like people say like i want to add the
new text boxes when i click on the
button
so
i can write it very well so either it
will be a text box or it could be the
new element you want to add it so
document.createelement
is one very very common
i would say the function and later on
you can use the typical dom
functions like i can talk about create
next node or append child so using this
combination you can easily do so
next what is the difference between call
and apply very common question so the
call method
whatever the method you have it in a
call
these
method arguments are provided
individually okay along with
this value but in apply what happens
arguments are provided in the form of
array
along with this value that is the only
difference between call and apply
so what would be the output of the below
javascript code as you can see right now
we've written a one object name called
student provided one property called
college with abc
after reducing object dot create passing
this student as an object itself and
after that you're saying delete
student1.collagenconsole.log
student.com so what would be the value
for this
so it is very simple it is very simple
example of object orientation so the
output will be what abc as we are
accessing the property of
student object so certainly the value
will be what
abc for sure now
what would be the output for below
javascript code as you can see now we
have written a one
function
for and it is written 11 so we are
saying type of
so this will certainly refer to what to
the error
reason is why because a function
definition can have only single
reference variable
as its name that's why exactly it will
be throwing what an error to you
how do you remove the duplicate
value from the javascript array it is
very simple we have called filter
function so the filter method i can
basically call it and three arguments it
may be expecting it the name of the
array the current element and the index
of the current element so that it can
remove all the duplicate elements from
there so how do you remove the duplicate
elements from javascript array so it is
same way i told you like
first it takes three parameters
so using the filter method and by using
the for loop so the empty array is used
for sorting all the repeating elements
so like that you can simply make it more
easy
so how can you draw a simple javascript
dom so you can say it is a very simple
javascript dom elements which are there
where you can have the document and then
the html
and followed by all child elements like
a head tag body tag body may contain
further child elements like an anchor
tag
so these are all basically known caller
presentation elements through which this
complete html hierarchy will contain
inside this we will discuss some of the
frequently asked questions in php
interviews
now the questions are categorized in two
sections beginner and advanced questions
so without any further ado let us get
started with the beginner questions
now the most basic question
is what is php
so php stands for hypertext preprocessor
it is a server-side scripting language
that is embedded into html and is
generally used for dynamic web
development php is also a very
compatible language that is it also
works efficiently with almost 20
different databases such as mysql post
resequal etc
next question what is a session in php
now sessions in php are used to store
data for users under a unique id which
can be then used across multiple web
pages of a website
next what is peer in php now peer
stands for php extension and application
repository
it is a framework and repository for the
reusable components focus on reusable
components of php containing code
snippets and libraries
next
is php considered a case sensitive
language so this is a very often asked
questions in interviews
so php is partially case sensitive since
variables in php are case sensitive
while functions and user defined
functions are not
next
name
different types of data types in php
so different data types in php include
integer float
string
boolean
array
object
null and finally resource so there are
total eight different data types that
exist in php
next question
how is echo different from print
now echo it can output multiple strings
at a time while in case of print it can
output only a single string
now echo does not have a return value
while print always returns one
that is the reason that is echo is
faster because it does not have to
return a value
while it is print is slower in
comparison to echo because it always
returns a value
now
as you can see
both of these commands echo and print
are used in the exact same way
next
what are the rules for naming a variable
now there are certain rules which you
have to follow or certain
good coding practices which you have to
follow while naming a variable in your
php code
so variable name must always begin with
underscore or a letter so it cannot
begin with a number or a special
character for that matter next variable
names can include numbers but not
special characters so
suppose you want to name your variable
number one two three so you can use this
variable but you cannot use number at
the red one two three since special
characters are not included
next a variable in php is declared using
this dollar sign followed by the
variable name now as you can see this is
how we declare a variable dollar my
underscore variable you can also put a
number in between or at the end while
naming a variable just not at the start
next
name some popular php frameworks so some
of the popular php frameworks include
symphony codeigniter cake php and
laravel
moving on
how to check if a defined variable is
null or not
so is a thank function is used to check
if the defined variable has any value or
not so to use this suppose you have this
block of code in front of you so
suppose you want to check if this x
variable that you've defined is null or
not so what you do is you put the is it
function inside the if condition and it
will return
true if it's
not null
while it will return false
if it is a null value since it is not
null it returns true and we can
display echo as variable x is not null
while in the case of variable y it is a
null value sin so
the if condition will be false and it
will not display anything
next
how are objects in php passed so objects
in php are always passed by value not by
reference
next question
how to display output directly to the
browser now
in cases you want to display your output
directly onto the browser while running
a piece of code
you can use it use
these special tags
to display an output directly to the
browser now as you may notice
these tags does not contain the php
written you can use them directly and
replace php with an equal to sign
followed by what you want to display and
end it with a question mark and a
closing bracket
moving on
what is defined function used for in php
now define is used to declare a constant
in php
also in contrast to the variables
there's no need for a dollar sign before
declaring a constant since the value of
a constant does not change
now this is how you can use the defined
function to declare a constant suppose
we want to declare the value of pi as
3.14 throughout your php code
and
which cannot be changed so we can use
define for that next question is related
to this question since
what is constant functioning used for in
php then so constant function returns
the value of a constant it is not used
to define a constant but it returns the
value of a constant so
suppose you define a function constant
using this defined function and you want
to return this value
you can use this constant function for
that
next
is multiple inheritance supported in php
so php only supports single level
inheritance which means a class can be
extended from only one class using the
keyword extended
next
what are the different types of loops in
php so php consists of a while loop
a do while loop a for loop and finally a
for each loop so php consists of total
for loops
next question
how to concatenate two strings in php
now
two strings can be easily concatenated
using the dot operator in php now to do
that i'll show you with the help of a
code suppose you want to concatenate or
join these two strings str1 hello guys
and the second string would be unwelcome
to simply learn and want to display
these strings together so to do that you
need to use this dot operator in echo as
you can see
this dot operator so first you write
this name of the first string then
followed by the dot operator i've given
this space
and then the next order operator because
this is also going to considered as a
string and then the third string
variable
and this is how you concatenate two
strings
next question what is the use of
function num ar argument now this
function as you can see
is used to return the number of
arguments passed in a function so
suppose you pass a certain number of
arguments in a function and want to know
how many
values or arguments were passed
you can use this function for that so
suppose
in this
sample code you want to know how many
arguments were passed
in this
sample function so to do that we declare
a variable number of arguments and we
will equal it to the function of number
function number argument now we will
display it
and this sample has passed three
arguments so the output would be three
moving on
what are super global variables in php
now some predefined variables in php are
known as super global variables because
they are always accessible from any
function file or class regardless of the
score so in all in all they are globally
accessible so suppose you write a piece
of code and you declare a variable
inside it it would be a local variable
and could be accessed only in that part
of the code
but in case of super global variable
they are accessible throughout the
entire code
they include
global server request posts get files
enb cookie and session
moving on
how to invoke single line and multi-line
comments now a single line comment in
php can be made using this hash followed
by the comment or
double slash followed by the comment
while in case of multi-line comments you
can use this hash star and write your
comments in multiple lines and enclose
it with a star and
slash
what i'm going to do now is i am going
to show you
the
use of these comments in actual vs code
now let us take this block of code for
example now suppose you want to add a
com single line comment after this
variable so what you will do is
you can use this double slash
this
is
a
variable
also you can use
slash
this is also a
variable
so this is a single line comment now if
you try to write something else
after this in the next line it will take
it as part of the code not part of the
comment
so what do you do
when you need to write multiple lines of
comment so suppose
you need to write two three lines about
this
line of code what you will do is you
will use a slash
star
now write the comment
this
is
displaying
simply learn
so this is a three line comment
which you can end simply
by star and a slash
this is how you write single line and
multi-line comments now let's move on to
the next question that is name some
common applications of php so some of
the most commonly used php applications
are system functions
firm handling so php is very commonly
used to handle the forms that you see on
the web pages
cred tasks now crud tasks are create
read update and delete so when you will
be working with databases this is a very
important part of using databases that
is crud and php is used very commonly in
that
next accessing cookies variables and set
keys
and finally data encryption php provides
security through some of its frameworks
which can be used
and is used very commonly throughout a
lot of websites
so now that we have gone through the
beginner level questions that are
frequently asked in php interviews let
us now move on to the advanced level
questions
so the first question would be how can
you execute a php script from the
command line
now a php script from a command line can
be executed by by opening the command
line
and inside the command line you have to
specify the name of the script or name
of the php file that you want to run
suppose you want to run a php underscore
script.php
so you type in the name
of the php script that you want to run
and that particular php script will be
executed
next
differentiate between a dollar variable
and double dollar variable so
what is the difference between the two
now in case of a single dollar variable
is it is a simple variable that is
simply used to store data so as we
discussed earlier it is a variable that
we defined to store different data types
that is integer float strings etc
while
a double dollar variable is a reference
variable of variable so
this is used to reference already
existing variables
now to use
or to understand how these two work
you can see this particular block of
code here now in this code what you need
to focus on is this is a simple variable
hello which contains the string welcome
to simplylearn and we have defined
another variable as where
which contains a string hello now in
this echo as you can notice what we are
doing is we are using this
also before that you need to notice is
this is
the same string as the name of this
variable so first we are displaying this
variable
and then we are referencing this
variable here
so what it is doing is it is referencing
the value to another variable so hello
variable is being referenced so
when you execute this block of php
script what you get the output is hello
since this is the variable hello and
after that what you'll
get is welcome to simply learn since
this variable is a reference to this
variable
next
differentiate between get and post
method now
get method is used to submit form data
while post method is also used for the
same
feature
so the difference between them is get
method sends data as part of php page
url
sorry web page url while a post method
sends data through http header
in get
the data since the data has been sent
through the url it is displayed in the
url of the webpage so it is not secure
while in case of post method it is a
secure form of
data transfer
hence
when developing a website for some
security purposes
usually we prefer post method
next up how to connect to a database
using a php script
now suppose
if you
are asked this question in an interview
what you need to do is you need to just
write this block of code and explain it
to the interview now suppose we have a
php script
and we want to connect it to a database
what we need to do is we will create
three different
variables that is server name username
and password now
what we are going to do is we will
create another variable con that will be
used to connect it and then we'll use
the
mysqli functions which will then
pass these variables to create a
connection so these variable values are
localhost username password these are
the default values now to check if the
connection is connected
what we are going to do is we will
use an if condition
if the con variable
gets and connect error we will display a
error message that is connection field
if not we will display connected
successfully
now as you can see here
these names can be the name of the
server that you're trying to connect i
have used localhost username password
for the default values you can use the
name of the database that you're trying
to connect your php script to
next up
what does final class and final method
mean in php
now a final class in php means that the
class cannot be extended
while a final method means that it
cannot be overridden
now as you can see in this block of code
we have used the final keyword for a
class and the final keyword for a
function
now suppose
this final class
is
being inherited by this child class what
the program will return is an error
because once you use this final keyword
this class cannot be inherited and
similarly
suppose this function is trying to be
overridden
by this part of the code
it cannot be because we have used the
final function
next question
differentiate between function
overloading and overriding
now function overloading the same
function is used for different purposes
based on the number of arguments inside
the function while in case of function
overriding
the same name and same argument function
is used in parent and child class
respectively to change the behavior of
parent class method now let me show you
and demonstrate the difference with an
example so
let us look at this code so suppose you
have a function named show title
which does have contain a single
parameter and displays when called upon
using this parameter displays function1
now if you want to use the same
name of the function for a different
purpose what you can do is you can
increase or change the number of
parameters inside the function that is
it now contains two parameters so when
the same function is called using two
parameters it will function differently
and display function overloading so this
is how function overloading works next
from this piece of code we can
understand function overriding suppose
you display a function demo in a base
class and you want to override this demo
function inside the derived class so
what you do is you make another function
with the same name inside the derived
class with some different properties as
you can see it displays something
different
now you create an object for the base
class and when you use this base class
object to call this demo function
you can use the properties of this
function here while if you create
another object that is object 2 for the
derived class and you use this object to
call upon the same demo function you are
overriding this base class demo function
that was inherited instead
what it will use is it will use the
properties of the derived demo function
so that is how you overload or override
a class
function in php now let's move on to the
next question that is differentiate
between equal to equal to and triple
equal operator
so a double equal operator is generally
used to check if the value of two
operands are equal or not it is
generally used in case of conditional
statements
while a triple equals to operator
performs a type save comparison which
means that will that it will only return
true if both operands have the same type
and the same value
so
you can understand this more with this
piece of code so suppose
in this case
since they both are equal it will return
true while in this case they both have
the
same
type hence it will return true now
let us
next check this equals to equal so since
they both are 1 and in php it will
display as true since they are equal
while when you are type checking that is
you are checking if they are equal with
the same type and same value it will
display a false since one is an integer
and the other one is a string value
also if you check two different strings
with the type save it will also display
true
next question
how does exception handling work in php
so when an exception is thrown
code following the statement will not be
executed and php will attempt to find
the first matching catch block so if an
exception is not caught a php fatal
error with will be issued with an
uncaught exception and exception can be
thrown and caught within php
so what we do is we use this try and
catch
method to
try the code and if an error occurs we
can catch
if an exception occurs we can throw it
and the catch function will catch
the exception and if doesn't we do not
include the catch function it will
result in a fatal error
next up
differentiate between require and
include now require if a required file
is not found it will throw a fatal error
and stop the code execution while in
case of include if an essential file is
not found it will produce a warning and
still execute the remaining scripts so
as you can see both of these include and
require i use in the exact same way with
different functions next up
explain different types of errors in php
now php consists of mainly three errors
notice
warning and a fatal error now notice is
a non-critical error which means that
something minor went wrong during
execution and
a lot of times you just don't pay
attention to it
a warning is a critical error now it is
given in condition where suppose an
include function
that we just discussed in the previous
question
then to retrieve a non-existent file so
suppose you use an include function and
the file does not exist it will display
a warning
and final is a fatal error so it is a
critical error resulting in termination
of the code so as we discuss in the try
and catch part of the question if
an exception is thrown and we do not
have a catch function for it it will
display a fatal error which will return
in termination of the code
next question
how to call a function by a reference
so ampersand sign is used to call a
function by reference now in case of
reference the actual value is modified
if the value passed inside the function
is also modified while in case of value
the
value of the original
value does not change
so this piece of code here
is
an example of how you can call a
function by reference here as you can
see this ampersand sign will call this
function by reference and any changes
made in the variables here
will affect the original ones next
question
create a singleton class in php so how
do we create a singleton class in ph
before that let's have a look at what is
a singleton class now a singleton class
in php is a class that can have only one
object and hence provides only a single
point of access so in generally
generally in class you can create as
many objects as you want and it will in
turn create
different access points into that block
of code so in a singleton class you can
only create a single object hence
singleton so this piece of code as you
can notice is used to create a singleton
class
now in to create a singleton class
you need to have the constructor
function private
now here
as you can see a singleton class is
created using this private construct
and it then
checks
if there's only one instance created and
if it is
it functions properly and displays
initialize only once
next question
how to encrypt a password using php
so php
can be used for encryption techniques
now the password underscore hash
function creates a hash password from
the password string using hashing
algorithm so suppose you create a
password string and enter your password
as password address one two three and
you put it inside the password has hash
function
so what it will generate is we are
echoing this generated hash
so what it will generate is
this so this is the
this is random it changes every time you
generate the password since it is
encrypted and
same when you pass
this password to the database using
hashing algorithm even in the database
the password will not be visible so your
data is secure
next question
mention different sorting functions for
errors in php now let us understand this
question in the vs code so
php consists of different sorting
functions which you can use to sort and
give an array automatically so if you
want to sort an array in ascending order
what you need to do is use this sort
function so it will sort this array in
ascending order now if you want to sort
it in descending order
use r sort that is reverse sort
similarly suppose you want to
sort an array in terms of value in
ascending order so you need to use a
sort function that is this so in terms
of value what in terms of value means is
suppose in a given error there are keys
and values
so it will sort the array based on the
values that is this 22 27 and 37 so the
array will be the same since
the values are already sorted now if you
want to sort the array in according to
key that is this
you can use k sort that is key sort
function that is provided in php so in
case of key sort
what it does is it will sort the array
in key that is the first one would be d
that is duke second m mac and the third
r that is raw
now
if you want to sort
this
array
in descending order in terms of value
you use instead of a sort you use a
reverse sort similarly if you want to
sort an array in terms of key
in descending
you use k instead of k sort k r sort
that is k reverse sort so these are the
different sorting functions that are
inbuilt into php
moving on
what will be the output of the following
code now
if this code is given
let me give you some time and try to
pause this video and think of what will
be the output of the following code
so the output of this code will be 21
comma 21 or 2 1 comma 2 1.
how did it happen
but before that if you got it correct
congratulations
but if you want to understand it see
a is a variable that contains the value
1 while a b is a variable that is
getting the value of a variable through
reference
now we make changes in the b variable
with 2
followed by this variable again which is
calling the value of a by reference so
if we make changes here we also make
changes in the value of a now if we
display this since the value of a is
already changed by reference it will
display 2 1 that is the value here and
again since the value of b is already 2
1 it will again display 2 1.
moving on
what are construct function and destruct
function in php so a constructor or
construct function is automatically
invoked
when a new object of a class is created
and then can be used to initialize value
in class
so when you create an object
an object for a class a constructor
function is automatically invoked
but this can also be so it does not
contain any value when it is invoked but
you can also use this construct function
to initialize some properties to give
some properties to the class
which will act as its default properties
if nothing or
no new properties are given to the class
next is a destruct now a distract is
automatically invoked when an object of
a class is destructed suppose you end
the part of the code of a class you want
you are destroying the object when
you're ending the piece of code a
destruct function is automatically
invoked to clean up the resources
next
is how can php and javascript interact
now php and javascript can not directly
interact with each other since php is a
server-side scripting language while
javascript is a client-side language
but there is a way that these two
wonderful languages can interact with
each other so we can swap variables
since php can produce javascript code to
be implemented by the browser so yes you
can produce javascript code from php
which can then be implemented by a
browser and then it is probable to pass
those precise variables back to php
via a url
next question is
explain type hinting in php
now in php type hinting is used to
specify the expected data type that is
array object interface etc for an
argument in a function declaration
now during a function call suppose if
arguments does not match the expected
data type the runtime will display an
error and the probe that is a fatal
error and the program will then
terminate now in this code here what we
are doing is we are type hinting so this
is this code is for string type hinting
and this code is for integer type
hinting now if these
particular set of functions that have
already specified the type
they are expecting does not
receive the same type of variable inside
them
the
program will return in a fatal error and
it will terminate
so
moving on to our final question of this
video
write a class so yes this is a an
assignment a kind of assignment for you
guys so what you need to do is you need
to write a class to solve the following
question which i'm going to say so
implement a class named basketball we
all like basketball right so implement a
class name basketball with an attribute
named baskets so you have to create an
attribute name baskets and initialize it
to 0 as the starting position
and then
create a method name score now when the
score method is invoked the baskets must
increase by one so let's see the
solution now so this is how you create a
class that is basketball
now inside this class what we are going
to do is we are going to initialize the
number of baskets that is this variable
as 0 as the starting position so to do
that what we are going to do is we will
be using construct function as we
discussed to initialize some
default properties for the class so this
construct function is
used to initialize this
basket's variable to zero now suppose we
do not call this function score which is
increasing the number of baskets
the default value will be displayed as
zero every time now suppose we invoke
this core function every time a basket
is code
this will increase the number of baskets
by one
so this is pretty simple and this is how
you create a simple class which will
perform
the following question
sql is a very important technology that
is used in the iit industry
professionals working as application
developers web developers data analysts
data scientists software testers and
cyber security experts need to know sql
in this video we will cover 30 important
sql questions that are most frequently
asked in the interviews
so before i begin make sure to subscribe
to the simply launch channel and hit the
bell icon to never miss an update
now these questions consist of a set of
theoretical and practical questions
so we will use different commands
functions joints and other
functionalities in excel to solve the
problems
so let's get started with the first
question
so the first question is to state the
difference between where and having
clause in sql
now wear and having are very widely used
in sql to solve specific problems
now let's look at the difference one by
one
so where clause is used to filter the
records from the table based on the
specified condition and can be used
without the group by clause on the other
hand having clause is used to filter the
records from groups based on specified
conditions
now where clauses cannot have aggregate
functions so you cannot use sum count
average min and maximum functions in the
where clause
while in the having clause you can
operate on aggregate functions
and those aggregate functions are used
to filter values from a group
now where clause is implemented on rows
or at row level
so for each row of data you have the
where condition applied
having clauses are implemented on
columns so for each column of data you
have the having condition applied
now another important difference between
wear and having is that the where clause
is executed before the execution of the
group by clause and after the execution
of the from clause
on the other hand the having clause is
executed after groups are created
now we will learn more about where and
having and understand the usage better
when we tackle practical problems in
this video
now moving to our next question
which is
how is drop different from truncate
so drop and truncate are two different
commands
so drop command is used to drop the
whole table removing the table
definition and its contents while
truncate deletes all the rows from the
table
we can drop the whole table structure in
one go so the view of the table does not
exist
by using the truncate command the
existence of all the rows in the table
is lost but the view in the table exists
now integrity constraints
will be removed in drop command while
the integrity constraints will not be
removed when you use the truncate
command
now moving to our third question now
this is a practical question so we will
be using a
table which is present in my mysql
database so the table name is called
employees and i want to find the lowest
salary of the employees in each
department you can see here this is how
my employees table
looks
and
the output query would be something like
this
so here since i want to find the lowest
salary of the employees so i'm using a
min function to find the lowest salary
in the table
and then
i am grouping
all the employees and the results by
department so let's do this on mysql
workbench
okay so here i am on my mysql workbench
first let me go ahead and create a new
sql script so i'll click on this
and that will create a new script
okay so here we'll write our commands
all right
so
our question was to
find the
lowest salary
for each department
okay so i have given my comment to make
my commands
and whatever i am doing more readable
so
first before i proceed
i need to
select my database so i am going to use
my sql underscore intro database
so i'll write use sql underscore intro
now this database has a lot of tables
that we'll be using in this
interview questions
video i'll run it okay
we are in our sql intro database
now there is a table called
employees let me show you the table
first
if i write select star from employees
okay so here you can see this is the
table i'm talking about
now these are the
rows
that are present in the table we have 20
rows and here you can see the different
columns we have the employee id employee
name each gender
we have the department city and salary
now this is the same table that we have
also used
in our other videos that are already
live on youtube
okay
so
let's solve our question to find the
lowest salary for each department
now
for that
i'll write
select
i'll select my department column which
is dept
comma
and then
to calculate the lowest salary or to
find the lowest salary i'm going to use
the min function so that will return the
minimum salary
present in the salary column
so i'll write min salary as i'm giving
an alias name as let's say
lowest
underscore salary
from
my table name that is employees
then i'll write
group by
department
now i'm grouping it by department
because we want to find the lowest
salary of the employees in each
department
now let's run and see the result
there you go
i'll just
move it to the top so that you can see
the results clearly
okay
so here we have total seven departments
you can see at the bottom
and
in these seven departments you can see
in sales seventy thousand let's say
dollars was the lowest salary in
marketing we had 55 000 as the lowest
salary similarly if i scroll down we
have other departments like
tech i.t finance and hr so
these are the lowest salary
in each department
all right
now moving to our next question
so our fourth question is
which query will help you fetch unique
values from a column in a table
so this is a multiple choice question
which is another type of question that
is often asked in the sql interviews
now we have multiple queries here and
you need to choose the right query that
will solve our problem so
since i want to
get the unique values from a column in a
table
so the right option
would be to use the distinct keyword in
the query so if i write select
dixtent followed by the column name
let's say you want to find the distinct
cities or the distinct departments in
the employees table so the query would
be select distinct city or let's say
department from the table name that is
employees
hence this is the right option if you
want to find any unique values from a
column
now moving to the
fifth question
now the fifth question says
it is actually a similar question here
we want to write the sql query to fetch
unique departments from the employees
table
so as we saw this is our employees table
and if you want to find the unique
departments from the employees table you
can just write select
distinct
then followed by the column name
which is departments here so dept from
employees
let's
do this on our mysql workbench
okay so let me just scroll down
and i'll
give a comment here
that is we want to find the unique
departments
so the query would be
select
then i'll use the distinct keyword if i
hit tab it will auto complete
then
i have my column that is department from
my table name that is employees
if i run this
the query will give us
the unique departments that are present
in the table so here we have total seven
unique departments in the table you can
see here we have sales marketing product
tech id
finance and hr
but
if you see our original table which is
the employees table
so there are total
20 records
and if you see the department column
there are
multiple departments to which each of
these employees belong to
ok
now moving ahead
now the sixth question is to write an
sql query to fetch the unique values of
departments and print their length
now
this question consists of two parts
first we need to fetch the unique values
of departments that we saw in our fifth
question
and then we want to print the length of
each of the departments so for that i'm
using the distant keyboard to find the
unique departments and then
i'm using the
inbuilt length function that is present
in mysql to find the length of the
department
and then i am
using an alias that is length underscore
department from employees so let's say
this on
our workbench
okay
so let me
give a comment
i'll say
unique
departments and length
okay
so the query would be
i'll write
select
distinct
department
and then
let me just scroll down
i'll give a comma
and use my inbuilt length function see i
am hitting tab to auto complete
and inside the length function i will
give my column name that is department
i will give an alias as
department underscore
length
from my table that is
employees this is pretty simple
so first i am finding the unique
departments and then using the length
function i am finding the
length of each department
let's run and see
okay you can see the result here so
sales the length is five
marketing the length of marketing is
nine so basically you are counting the
number of characters that are present in
each of the departments so in sales
there are total five characters in
marketing there are total nine
characters in product there are total
seven characters in it we have just two
letters i and t so hence the
length is two similarly finances
7 and hr is 2 because we have just two
letters h and r
okay so this is another variation of
using distinct along with
any inbuilt function
all right
now moving to the seventh question
the question is what is the use of
dative function in sql
now dative
returns the number of days between two
date or date time or time stamp values
so d diff is another
crucial
inbuilt function
that is present in mysql
so here is how you can use the datedif
function so it will return the number of
days between two dates or date time or
time stamp value so here i have two date
values that is
10th of
april 2021 and
i have
30th of
march 2021
so this query will give us the
total number of days that lie between
these two dates and similarly
here is another example of using the
datedif function
so i want to calculate the total number
of days that are present between today's
date so i am using the now function and
between 20th of april 2021
so let's do this demo on the workbench
all right
first i'll give a comment
saying
dated function
okay
now the way to use this
i'll write select
and then
you can see here once i type date
mysql workbench is automatically
suggesting some of the
inbuilt functions i'm going to use
datedif
and within datedif i'm going to pass in
two values so i'm passing into date
values let's say 2021
april
so i'll write 0 4 and let's say
10th of april
i'll give another comma
and i'll pass in my second date value
that is going to be
30th of
march
2021
all right
now another thing to note here is
the
date value should be present inside
quotations
now if you want you can give an alias as
well
i'll write as
total days
let's run it
there you go it has given us the output
as 10 so there are total 10 days between
31st of march
to
10th of april
now let's see another example
i'll write select
date diff
and we'll pass in
my now function so the now function
returns the
current
date that is today's
date
and i'll give another date value let's
say
2021
april
20th
now we'll see the results
if you want you can give an alias name
so that the output is more readable here
i'll run it
okay
so between
today's date and
my previous date that was 20th of
april
there are total 49 days
so today's date is actually
8th of june so between
20th of april and 8th of june there are
total 49 days
all right
now moving ahead
now in the eighth question we want to
write
an sql query to display the departments
that have
more than two employees
so this is our employees table that we
have been using
and here is how the
command looks like so here
we are using both group by and having
now i am grouping by department because
i want to
display the departments that have more
than two employees now for the second
filter i am using the
count function of the employee ids
and checking if the employees
in each department are more than two or
not
let's do this
let me
move down a bit
and i'll give a comment
departments with
more than
two employees
okay
now let's write our query
so i want to select
the department
and then
i'm using the count function to count
the
employee ids in each
department or the employees
present in each department
from my table that is employees
i'm going to group by department
and then i'll use having
my count of
employee id
this should be greater than 2
so our query will return only those
departments which have more than two
employees
let's run and see
there you go
so we have total four departments that
is sales product tech and i t
where we have more than
two employees you can see here sales has
four employees product has three
tech has four
and it has three the rest of the
departments like finance hr and others
have less than two employees
now if you want you can give an alias as
well
let's see as total employees
okay
let me run it again
and here you can see i have the
column name as total employees
okay
so moving ahead
the ninth question we want to display
the details of the employees for all the
departments except marketing
now
here i have my employees table
now if i were to display all the details
of the employees apart from
marketing department
i can give a condition like where
department
not equal to marketing so this is the
way how you write not equal to so you
use the less than and greater than
symbol
another way to do is use the exclamation
mark
and give equal to so this means
select all the employees where
department is not equal to marketing
now let's do this
i'll move down a bit
and we'll give a
comment as
details of employees apart from
marketing
so the query would be select
star from employees
i'm using star because i want to display
all the details that means i want to
display all the columns
then i am going to use my where
condition where
department
not equal to
marketing
i'll put marketing under
quotes
let's run it and see the results
there you go
so we have
total
18 rows of information
and if you see the department column we
have
all the departments apart from marketing
now if you remember
our employees table had total 20 rows of
information out of which two are missing
which means there were two employees who
were from marketing department and those
departments we are
not displaying
now
another way to do is
to use
exclamation mark and equal to
so this also means
select all the employees where
department is not equal to marketing
let's run this you see here
it gives us the same result and has
returned us
18 rows of information
leaving apart
the employees from the marketing
department
all right
now moving ahead
so our 10th question is to write an sql
query to print the details of the
employees who have joined before
april 2010 and after
may 2005
so here is my employees table
and
this is my sql query so here we are
using
just a where condition to filter our
results
and
my condition is
the employee should have joined after
may 2005 so i have written
after
31st of
may 2005 and before april 2010 which is
before
31st of
march 2010.
let's do this
i'll
give a comment here
we'll write employees
joined
before
april
2010
[Music]
and
after
may 2005
now let's write our sql query so i'll
write select
star from
employees
where
my date of join if you see here i have a
column called date of join which has the
details about the day on which the
employee had joined
the company
so i'm going to write where date of join
is greater than
31st of
may
2005 so i'll write
2005
this is one of the formats to use
date values
so this is the year value this is the
month value and this is the d
value and
my date of join
should be
less than
31st of march 2010 so i'll write 2010
march
31st
i hope
you were able to understand this
date of join greater than 31st of may
2005 means
after may 2005
and data joined less than
31st of march
2010 this means
employees joined before
2010 april
let's run it
okay so we have total three employees in
our table you can
see the
date of join
and all of them have joined
after may 2005 and before april 2010
okay
now moving ahead to the 11th question
so here we want to find the employee
with the
third highest salary from the table
so i have my employees table here
and my command would look something like
this so here we are going to explore how
to write
sub queries in sql so
i am using a sub query here where i am
trying to find
the
employees who have the
top three salaries or the top three
employees who have the highest salaries
and from that i am going to filter out
my third highest salary employee so
let's do it on our workbench
okay
so i'll come down and let me give a
comment as
third highest salary
okay
so
let me first write down my sql query and
then i'll explain so i'll write select
star from
after that i'll start a bracket and
write my inner query so i'll write
select
star from
employees
order by
salary
descending
then i'll use my limit keyword
and i'll write limit 3
as i'll give an alias name let's say t
and then
i'm
again going to use
my order by salary
limit
one
okay now let me explain you the flow
so first let me run the inner query i'll
select my inner query
and i'll run it
so the inner query returns
my top three employees who have the
highest salary and this is ordered in
descending order since i used salary
descending
now let me just
use this okay now you can see it clearly
so these are my top three employees who
have the highest salary so josef has the
maximum salary followed by angela and
then we have jack
now from this i want to return
only
the record for jack because jack is the
employee
who earns the third highest salary so
for that i am going to
use the result written by my
sub query or the inner query and on top
of this
i am going to order the salary and say
limit equal to 1 so i am again ordering
this salary in ascending order so what
will happen
jack will appear at the top angela will
be at the second place and joseph will
come to the third place and from there
i'm using limit one so that i can only
get
the record for jack
now if i run the entire query
you see the result i have my
employee name as jack who earns the
third highest salary
okay
now moving ahead to the 12th question
the question is to print all the
alternate records in a table so here is
my employees table and from this table i
am going to print all the alternate
records for example i am going to print
my employee id 101 then i'm going to
skip 102 and print 103 followed by 1 0 5
1 0
7 1 0 9 so all the
employee ids that have an odd value
and you can look at this example in
another way of displaying the employees
which have an employee id
of even numbers so 102 104 106 and so on
now the way to do is
either you can use a simple select
clause and say employee id
percentage or modulus 2 equal to 0 which
means i want to filter only those
employees which have an even employee id
else
what you can do is you can use a cte as
you can see here
so cte or the common table expression is
a temporary named result set that you
can reference within a select insert
update or delete statement now it is
used to simplify complex joins and sub
queries and to provide a means to query
hierarchical data
now let's
write this query on our workbench and
see how it works
before that let me explain you i am
using a few
new functions such as row number this
will
create a row number for each of the rows
or the records present in my table
and then
from this cte i am going to use my
filter class or the where clause
where rn which is row number percentage
2 equal to equal to 1 so this will
return
only the odd records from the table
let's see how to do it
okay
so
i'll give a comment
print
alternate
records okay
now i'll start with my
simple query which is select star from
employees
where
let's say i want to find only the even
employee ids
or the employees who have an even
employee id so i can use employee id
percentage 2 equal to 0 so it has to be
a perfect division
and the result should be zero only then
i can get only the
even employees if i run this
okay there was an error here it should
be employees
i'll run it again
you can see here i have printed the
alternate records in a table so we have
skipped one zero one because it is not
divisible by two
i've started with one zero two followed
by one zero four
one zero six one zero eight
and then finally we have
120 or 120
now if you want
to print only the
odd records in the table you can use
employee id percentage 2 equal to 1
so you can see here i have 1 0 1 1 0 3 1
0 5 1 0 7 up to
1 1 9.
now the
best way to do this is
to use a common table expression of cte
so i'll start with
my command that is with cte
as
i'll
start with my bracket i'll write select
star
comma
then i'm going to use my row number
function
so i'll write
row number
then
i'll write over
then i'll use order by
employee id
so this
row number for each of the rows is going
to be created over my employee id column
and that is sorted in
ascending order i'll give an alias as rn
which stands for row number
from
my table that is
employees
i'll scroll down
and then i'm going to
close my bracket
i'll write select
let me remove the space here
okay i'll let select star
from cte
where
my
row number
percentage
2 equal to
1
now let's
see this from the top
so i have my commentable expression
where
i am
going to create a
row number column named as rn
and this row number column is based on
my employee id column which is sorted in
ascending order
and from that i am going to filter only
those row number values that are not
divisible by 2 or i am going to print
only the
odd records from the table so let's run
it and see the results there you go so
here if you mark i have my row number
column created
and i am filtering only the odd records
in the table so it starts with 1 3 5 7
and goes up to 19.
and similarly here you can see the
employee ids the name the age gender and
other information
now if you were to print
the even records in the table
the alternate even records you can use
rn percentage 2 equal to 0 let's see the
difference
and run this
there you go
so have my even row numbers starting
from 2 which goes up to
20
okay so this is how you can print
alternate records in a table
now moving to the next question
now in the 13th question we want to
write an sql query to fetch
all the duplicate rows in a table now
this is another crucial interview
question that is often asked in most of
the interviews
now i have a table
which is named as duplicate table and
here you can see i have some employee id
name and each and a few records are
duplicated for example
101 sam
40 the first record is duplicated and
you can see here it has the same
values
now if you mark
103
mary and 28 is not duplicated because
here the age is different so this is a
different person
than
compared to the third
name that we have
so this is how you can find
the duplicate rules in a table so i am
going to select my employee id name and
each and then count
all the
employee ids the names and each and
compare them with whether they are
greater than one or not so if they are
greater than one
then
i'll say that particular record is
duplicated or is present more than one
time in the table
let's
do this
implementation on our
workbench
okay
so i'll come down and let me give my
comment as
duplicate records
okay
so
let me first
show you the records that are present in
my table so i'll right select
star from
dup underscore
employees
i'll run it
okay you can see here i have my table
that we saw in the slides
so
employee id 101 with name sam and h
fought is duplicated
so we want to find this duplicate record
the way to do is
i'll write
select
e underscore id which is employee id
comma name comma age
comma i'm going to count all of them
so i'll write count star
as
duplicate
count this is my alias name
from
my table that is dup underscore
employees
i'll say
group by
employee id
name
and age
and then i'm going to use my having
clause saying having
count of
employee id
is greater than 1
and
count of
name
should also be greater than 1
and
my count of age
should also be greater than 1.
let's run it and see the results
okay there is some error here
the name of the table should be
employees
okay
let's run again
we have
our correct result
that is employee id101 with name sam and
each 40 is duplicated so the value is 2.
great now
moving ahead
now the 14th question is a bit tricky
wherein we want to display the employees
with exactly
two
a's in their name so you see here i have
my
employee names and
there are certain employees who have
just
two e's in their names so i want to find
those employees
only
now the way to do is
it is a bit tricky to understand i am
going to break it down and make you
understand
on my mysql workbench
so here you can just have a glance i
write select star from employees where
i am finding the length of my employee
name and then subtracting
my length
wherein i have
replaced my employee name
that has a with a
blank
and if this subtraction is equal to 2
then
that particular employee has two a's in
their names
so let me show this first
let me
first give my comment as
employees
with
two
e's okay
so first
i'm going to write a select statement
okay before that i'll show you
the records present in my table
okay if you see here
shane is one of the employees that has
just one e
in its name then we have mary 1 a
duin has one a but if you see sarah
sarah has 2a
in the name so we want to extract sarah
then
jack has 1a again if you see angela
angela has 2a it doesn't matter if it is
uppercase a or lowercase a we just need
to find
if the employees have two e's in their
name
and similarly if i scroll down let me
check if we have
any other employee with two a's in the
name marcus has one d bit has one sophia
has one
we also have amelia that has two a's
in its name or in her name
and we also have maya
okay
now
let me go ahead and write a sql query
and then i'll explain you what i'm
trying to do
i'll write select
i'm using the length function
and
in the length function
i'm going to replace
then i'll use another function called
upper
on top of employee name
i'll write
a and then replace it with a blank so
i'm using quotations to represent blank
from
employees
okay
let's run this and see the results
you see here
it has given us
the length
of the employee strings
after
replacing all the a's with a blank
so here
i'm essentially
converting my employee names to
uppercase
and i'm changing wherever there is an a
i am replacing
that a with a blank
and then i am finding the length
so this trick i am going to use
in my
final query so i will write select star
from
employees
where
what i'm going to do is
i'll bring this to the next line i'll
write
length of
employee name
minus
then
i am going to use my above
condition
i'll
copy this
i'll paste it here
and this value should be
2.
so what i'm doing is i'm first
finding out the length of my employee
name
from that
i'm subtracting
the length after replacing
the e is present in the employee name
with a blank and this value should be
equal to 2. the reason being we are only
trying to find the employees who have
two a's in their name
let's run and see the results
okay if you see here
we have sarah angela
emilia and maya who have two a's in
their name so we have
sarah
that has 2a angela has 2a amelia has two
a's
and then maya also has 2a
okay
now moving ahead
now the 15th question is given a string
how will you extract four characters
starting from the
second position
so i have my string here
which says michael balak now michael
balek you must be aware is a popular
footballer he is from germany and also
was the captain of germany
so from the string michael ballack i am
going to extract four characters
starting from the second position
you can use two inbuilt mysql functions
to
do this the first is called
sub str wherein we pass in the string
then we
give the position from where we want to
extract the characters so here i am
going to extract from the second
position so hence 2
and then the number of characters that
you want to extract which is 4.
the other way is to use the substring
function
which is again similar to the sub str
function
in the substring function also i am
first passing in my input string and
then giving my
starting position which is 2 and then i
want to extract 4 characters from it
let's do it
i'll give a comment
extract
strings
so here i am going to write select
first i am going to use sub str
which is my inbuilt function i am going
to pass in my input string which says
michael
ballack
and then
i will give my starting position which
is 2 and then the number of characters
that is 4.
let's run it and see the results
you can see here it has given us
i cha
so if you see m is at the first position
from the second position onwards i
needed four characters so m c h and e
these are the four characters starting
from the second position
similarly let me just copy this
and instead of
sub str i'm going to use the sub string
function i'll write just
ing that becomes substring
let's
select and run it
and this also returns the same result
suppose you wanted to extract
from the fourth position
you we wanted to extract let's say three
characters
let's see the results
it gives us h a and e if you see here
m is the first physician i is at the
second position c is at the third
position h starts from the fourth
position
so h a and e are the next three
characters starting from the fourth
position
so hence this is the result
all right now moving ahead
now my 16th question is on
how does self join
work
so self join joins a table to itself
so the table must contain a column x
that acts as the primary key and a
different column let's say y that stores
values that can be matched up with the
values in column x now
this might
not be really easy to understand you'll
get to know once we do this demo so i
have a table
which is called employee manager so this
is my table
now let me tell you how to interpret
this table we have five different
employees starting from employee id1 to
employ id5
gary gibbs smith latham and jimmy are
the different employees we have you have
their salaries and now you have
the employees reporting to which
manager
if you see
here gary's manager
id is three
so if you see a table at three we have
smith so gary is reporting to three
or in other words
smith has a employee under him who is
gary similarly
gibbs is reporting to manager id1 or
employee one which is gary so
gibbs manager is gary similarly if you
see for smith smith is reporting to the
person with manager id 4 or employee id
4 we have latham so litham has one
employee under him who is smith
now litham in our table has no managers
then we have jimmy who's reporting to
the employee id3 who is smith
ok
now i want to
use this table and return the name of
the manager for each employee
to do that i am going to use my self
join so here i am using
a self join to join both the tables
here both the tables mean i am using
the same table twice so i have written
select e dot employee id e dot employee
name then we have e dot manager id
then i am using another alias for
managers so m dot employee name as
manager underscore name from
employee underscore manager as e
this join means self join employee
underscore manager sm on
e dot manager id equal to e dot employee
id so this is my common column that is
employee id and manager id let's do it
all right
i'll give a comment here
saying self join
and i'll start with my self join i'll
write
select
let me first display my table i'll write
select star from
and my table name is
emp underscore manager
i'll run it
you can see the table here this is the
same table that we saw
in the slides
now i'll write my
join query i'll write select e dot
employee id
comma
e
dot
employee name
comma
e dot
manager id
comma
then i'm using another alias as m
for
finding the
manager name so m dot employee name as
manager name
there shouldn't be any space in the
alias name
then i'll write from
emp underscore manager as e
join
emp underscore
manager as
m
on
e dot
manager
underscore
id equal to m
dot emp underscore
id
let me run this and we'll see the
results
there you go
so gary
reports to
the manager id three so from the table
three
is for smith so gary's manager is smith
gibbs manager is gary
smith's manager is lithum and jimmy's
manager is smith
okay so this is how you can use self
join
now moving ahead with our
next question
so the 17th question
is on which of the following is called a
virtual table in sql so again we have a
multiple choice question
so the answer is
view you can see here
so view is a virtual table that has rows
and columns as they are in a real table
in the database now we can create a view
by selecting fields from one or more
tables present in the database
next moving to the 18th question
so here we want to write an sql query to
fetch the list of employees with the
same salary
again i am going to use a self join here
wherein i will join the same employees
table
and this is how my
query would look like so i am
selecting distinct employee id so e dot
employee id e dot employee name e dot
salary from employees
then i'm joining
employees as e on employees e1 where e
dot salary equal to e1 dot salary
because i want to fetch
the list of employees with the same
salary and i'm ensuring that
the employee ids from both the tables
are different
let's do it
i'll give a
comment here and write
employees
with
same salary
and i'll start with my
query i'll write
select
extinct
e dot
employee id
comma i'll write e dot
employee name
comma i dot salary
from
employees
as e
then
employs as
e 1
where
e dot salary equal to
e 1 dot
salary and
e dot
employee id is not equal to
e1 dot
employee id
i'll give a semicolon and let's print
the results
you see here we have
emilia
bayla
sheen and sarah
who have the
same salary so emilia and sheen have the
same salary of fifty five thousand
dollars bill and sarah have the same
salary of seven to two thousand dollars
okay
now moving to the 19th question
so the question is to write an sql query
to print one row twice
in results from a table
so i have a table here called employees
and i want to print
one row twice in the results
so to solve such kind of problems
you need to use the union all operator
in sql
so union all combines the result sets of
two or more select statements
it does not remove duplicate rows
between the various select statements
all the rows are returned
so let's say i want to print the
employee name and department for those
employees who are from the hr department
now to do this we can use the union all
operator you can see it here so i am
selecting my employee name the
department from my table employees as e
then i am giving my where clause where e
dot department equal to hr
and then i am using the union all
operator
then i am again selecting my employee
name department from employees with
another alias as e1 where e1 dot
department equal to
hr so let's do this
okay so i'll give my comment as
print
row
twice
okay
now
i'll start with my query i'll write
select
my employee name
comma the department
from
my table that is employs as e
then i'll use where
e dot department equal to
hr
then i am going to use the union all
operator
so the union all will combine the result
set of two or more select statements
then i am going to write select
emp underscore name
comma
my department
from
employees as
e1
where
e1 dot department
equal to
hr
i'll give a semicolon now let's run it
there you go you can see here
marcus and sophia are from the hr
department and we have printed them
twice in our results
coming to the next question
the question is
using the num table
write a query to add 10 when number is 0
20 the number is 1
else print the number itself
so you can see here i have my table
called num
and it has just one column which is
num id or number id
we have some
numbers here
and
from these numbers i want to add 10 if
the number is 0 20 if the number is 1
else i would print the number itself
so
to answer this question we'll use the
case statement in sql
so the case statement is sql's way of
handling if then logic
the case statement is followed by at
least one pair of when and then
statements
so here you can see i have my case
statement i'm writing one case
my column name and underscore id equal
to 0 then add plus 10
if it is 1 then add plus 20
else
we'll just return the number id
now let's do this
okay
i'll give a
comment saying using
case statements
okay first of all let me
display the values present
in my
num table you can see here this is my
table and there are total
12 rows
of numbers
now let's start with our
query i'll write
select
n underscore id
comma
then i'm going to write my case
statement so i will use the keyword as
case when
n underscore id equal to 0
i'll use then
n underscore id
plus 10
i'll write when
n underscore id equal to 1
then
n underscore id
plus 20
else
i'll just print an id
now i'll end my key statement i'll write
end as
an alias name let's say num underscore
ad
from my table that is
num
let's run and see the results
okay you can see here
my first number was 0 so since it was 0
we have added
num id or n id plus 10 so the result is
10
now
wherever
the num id is 1 for example here we have
added 20 so the
result or the output becomes 21.
similarly here the value was 0. so we
have added 10 the output is 10. and you
see here again here we had another one
so we added 1 to
20 so the result becomes 21
and for the rest of the numbers for
example 3
we had 2
the values are the same
ok
now moving ahead
so we
have a table called num1
and using this table we want to write a
query to find the sum of all positive
values and the negative values
so let's see the table first so this is
my table which is num1 you can see here
we have a list of integers
and
there are positive as well as negative
integers
so for positive values
and the negative values we want to find
the sum separately
so again for this we are using the
key statement you can see here i have
used
two key statements
i am writing select
and then i am using the case to find if
the number is greater than 0 which means
it's a positive number so i'm
finding out the sum and then i'm
checking
case when
the integer is less than 0 so it's a
negative number and i'm finding the sum
for the negative numbers as well
let's do this
okay
so
i'll give my comment
as
add
positive and
negative numbers
okay so let's start with our select
query
i'll write select
i'll use the sum function and inside the
sum function
i'll use my case statement so i'll write
case when
num
underscore
integer
okay before that let me just print the
values present in my
table so i'll write select star from
my table name that is num1
okay
so you can see here these are the values
or the list of integers that we have
there are some positive as well as
negative integers
okay let's continue with our query
so here i'm going to write case when
num underscore integer or int which is
my column name
if it is greater than 0
then
i'll return nom underscore
int
else i'll say 0
and end my case statement
i'll give an alias as sum of let's say
positive numbers
give a comma
then i'll use another sum function
and inside the sum function we'll use
the case statement to find
the sum of
negative numbers or integers
so i'll write num underscoring if it is
less than 0
then
num underscore int
else
0
and i'll end
okay
and i'll give another alias name as
let's say sum underscore any g which
stands for negative
pos is for positive integers
and then i'll write from my table that
is num1
let's
run it
okay there you go we have our results so
we have two columns
sum of positive integers and sum of
negative integers you can see the
results 19 and minus 14 respectively
okay now moving ahead
now
in question number 22 we want to list
the difference between
primary key and foreign key
so as you can see here
primary key is something that can
uniquely identify a record in a table so
if you consider a school database a
primary key would ideally be
the
role number or the registration number
of the student
because that is unique to all the
students in a school
now
foreign key is the field in the table
that is
primary key to another table
so suppose you have another table called
courses to which the
students of enroll 2
now
if you have a roll number or
registration number column in the
course table that becomes the
foreign key
now the other difference is primary key
don't accept or cannot accept null
values
while foreign key can accept null values
you can have only one primary key in a
table but you can have more than
one foreign key in a table
now coming to the 23rd question what is
the difference between primary key and
union
so you can have only one primary key in
a table as we discussed in the previous
question
but you can have more than one unique
key in a table a primary key column
cannot have null values but
union can accept null values
now if you assign a column as a primary
key you create a clustered index
and similarly if you assign a column
with union
you create non-cluster index
okay
now coming to the 24th question
what is a check constant in sql
so check constraints are used while
creating tables
check constraint
helps to limit or restrict the values
that can be inserted into a column
for example
we have a
table here
let's say dummy one
and
you want to ensure
that every time you insert the
age of
people or persons in the table
you want to make sure that each should
be always greater than zero
reason being a person cannot have or an
animal cannot have or a tree cannot have
a negative each
similarly you can set a constant for the
salary column in a table to ensure that
it is always greater than zero because
you cannot earn a negative salary or it
cannot be less than zero
now we are going to create a dummy table
on my mysql workbench
and see how
check constraints can be applied
okay
so let's give our comment as
check constraints
all right
so i'm going to create
a table
called
dummy
let's say underscore
sql
now this table
will have
a few columns first we have let's see
eid which stands for employee id
the dd type is integer and i'm going to
assign employee id as my primary key so
i'll write
primary key here
okay
i'll give a comma
next we'll have a city column
city column is of type var care or
varying character
i'll give the size as 30
and here
i am going to apply my check constraint
to this
city column
i am going to check
the city
should
take only
values as mumbai
let's see
i'll have my final column that is each
age is of type integer
and here i'm going to check my age
should always be
greater than 0 so i'll write check
age
greater than zero
okay
so our dummy sql table has
one primary key constraint and we have
applied two check constraints
on city and each column
let's run this
okay so we have created our table
successfully you can see it here
now
let's insert a few records and we can
see the difference
i'll write insert into
dummy
underscore sql
i'll write
values
i'll have my employee ids 101
i am giving my
city as mumbai
which is what we want
and let's see
i'll give my age as
10
now this should perfectly bore because
my city is mumbai and my age
is greater than zero
so
i should be able to insert this record
successfully you can see here
i have inserted
this record to the table
i'll write select star from dummy sql so
that you can check
let's run
it or there is some mistake i should
write from
okay
let's run it
you can see it here we have one record
or one row returned
now let's see we'll insert another
record
and this time i'm going to give my
employee ids 102 because it has to be
unique
and this time instead of mumbai i'm
going to give my city as let's say delhi
so i'm not following my check constant
where i am
supposed to give only mumbai
i am purposely giving
delhi here to see the difference if i
run this
let's see we'll have
ages 40 which is greater than
0
let's run it
you see here we get an error saying
check constraint dummy underscore sql
underscore
check is violated
similarly
let's see i'll change this to mumbai
again
and instead of 40 let's say i'll give us
minus 30
so your each can never be in negative
numbers
if i run this i get the same error my
check constraint has been violated
because each
should be greater than
0.
ok so this is how you can use check
constraints in sql
now coming to the 25th question
so given two tables a and b
you want to write a query to fetch
values in table b
that are not present in table a
now to answer this question
you can use the left join so what left
join does is
it returns all the rows from the left
table and only matching rows from the
right table
and i've used my
condition as a dot id which is in the
right table should be null
let's write this query on the
workbench
okay
so i'll give my comment
using
left join
first of all let me display my
tables i'll write select star from
a
where on this i have the
ids there are total five ids in table a
similarly
i'll copy this and
we'll see the values that are present in
table b
again i have five values there are a few
non-matching values as well so i want to
return those non-matching values that
are not present in table a
so for that
i'll write select
id
from
table b
i'll use left join
a
using my id column
this is another way to give the
condition
or you can use the on operator
then i'll give
where
a dot id is
null
let's run and see the results
there you go so 150
275 are not present in table a but are
present in table b
okay
now moving ahead
so now we look at the last set of five
questions
so these questions are based on the
popular northwind sample database
provided by microsoft now there are
several tables in this database so we
have an order table customers employee
products region table and others
we'll use our microsoft sql server to
solve the five questions
so my next question which is based on
microsoft sql server
the question is using the
north wind
database find the customers who don't
have any orders
okay so i am on my microsoft sql server
management studio so this is how the
interface looks like
and here you can see i have a list of
databases now to solve the last five
questions i am going to use the
northwind database if i expand this
i'll click on the plus sign you can see
there are a lot of tables that are
already present in the
database you can see here we have
customers employees employee territories
order details orders products region
shippers suppliers territories and more
okay
let me just collapse this
all right
so
to write my queries i am going to create
a
new query file
and here you see
i am currently on my master database i
am going to change this to
northwind database so that we can
utilize all the tables that are present
so my 26th question was to find the
customers who don't have any orders
so for that
i am going to use two tables
customers and orders
so
let me first give a comment
saying
customers
with
no orders
and now
let's go ahead and display the columns
that we have and see the
records present in the tables
customers and orders so first time
checking all the
columns and the rows present in the
customers table i'll
execute using this button or you can hit
f5 as well
okay you can see here there are total
91 customers these are all unique
customers you have total 91 unique
customer ids you see here the company
name of the customer
you have the contact name the contact
title address city to which the
customers belong to
then the region postal code country
phone fax number
okay
now let me just copy this query
and
now we'll check for the orders table
i'll write select star from
orders
and let's execute it or run it
okay so there are
total
830
rows of information so there were total
830 orders
or order ids we have the customer id now
this customer id is actually the
foreign key
for the orders table
but for the customers table customer id
is the
primary key and in the orders table
order id is the primary key
we also have the employee id again this
employee id is the foreign key for this
audis table
we have the order date
we have the required date ship date
ship wire which means
by which medium the order was shipped we
have the free charges ship name and
ship address as well
then you have the
city from which the item was shipped the
region postal code and the country
okay
now
let me use the distinct keyword i'll
write select
dixtent
i want to find the distinct
customer ids
from
my customers table
let's run and see how many unique
customer ids we have so there are total
91 customer ids or customers
now let's check for the orders table
let's run it and see the difference now
if you see here there are total
89
customer ids in the orders table which
means
there are two customers missing from the
orders table
and that implies those two customers
don't have any orders
so to
get the result i will use two different
queries
to derive at the same
output
so i'm going to select
my customer id
from
my table that is
customers
i'm going to use
where
my customer id
and then i'm going to use the not in
operator
i'm going to use a sub query
select
customer id
from
my orders table
close the bracket and i'll give a
semicolon
now what this query essentially does is
it is first going to
find all the customer ids that are
present in my orders table
and
in the outer query we are only going to
return
the customers that are present in
both the tables
and
we are going to
exclude those customers which are not
present in the orders table
so let's run and see the results we
should get two customer ids there you go
so these are the two customer ids which
are
present in the
customers table and are not present in
the orders table meaning that they don't
have any
orders in their name
now there is another way to do it
that is to use the not exist operator
wherein you can write another sub query
to get this same result we'll leave that
to you you can try this out using the
not exist operator as well
coming to the 27th question
using the orders table in the northwind
database we want to find all the
month and orders
so such problems you will face while
dealing with sales data so very often
sales executives would try hard to meet
their month and targets we want to
display all the orders made on the last
day of the month
so let's solve this question on our
microsoft sql server
okay so let me first give my
comment for the 27th question so the
question is to
find all the month-end orders so i'll
just write
month and orders
okay
now to get the month-end orders we are
going to use a
built in
eo month function which stands for end
of month
so let's start with the query
i'll write select
we are going to select the
employee
id
comma
i also want the order id
and
we want the order date
from
my table that is
orders
i'll
then give my where clause i'll write
where
my
order date
equal to and i'll use my
inbuilt function that is end of month
i
have hit tab to auto complete
and inside this function i'll pass in my
order date column
then i am going to
use the order by clause i am going to
order it by
employee id and the order id
i'll just move down and hit tab okay
let's
run the query
there you go
we have got 26 rows of information
you see on the left side we have the
employee ids the order ids and then we
have the order date column now if you
mark the values present in the order
date column these are all
the
end of
month date values you see this is 28th
of fab
then we have
31st of
july
we have 30th of june
so on and so forth
so these are the list of all the orders
that were placed
on the last day of the month coming to
the 28th question
we want to find the top five countries
with the highest freight charges in the
year 1997.
so freight charge is the amount paid to
a carrier company for the transportation
of goods from origin to another location
the freight charge is calculated based
on the mode of transportation and the
distance between the pickup place or the
pickup location and the destination
so let's try this out on the
microsoft server management studio
okay so let me go ahead and
give my
comment
so since we want to find the top five
countries with the highest freight
charges
i'll just give my comment as
highest
freight charges
okay
now
to solve this question
i'll just change this to
ght okay
we are going to use
our
orders table
so the way to do is i'll write select
i'm going to use the
top five so top is another
keyword or
an operator
so i'm going to find out the ship
country
and then
i'll calculate the average freight
prices so i'm going to use the average
inbuilt function
on top of my
column that is freight
i'll give an alias as
let's say
average
fret
there should be no space i'll give a
underscore
i'll write from my table that is
orders
i'll use my where clause where
and then i'm going to find the
year from my order
date column and this year should be
1997.
i'm going to
group it by
my ship country
and
i'll use
order by
my alias name that was average freight
and in descending order i'm going to
sort it
let's see the top five
shipping countries who have the highest
freight charges
these are the results you have austria
switzerland sweden canada and ireland
and here you can see the average freight
prices
sorted in descending order
okay
now moving ahead to the
29th question
so here we want to display the total
number of products in each category so
we have two different tables products
and categories so both these tables we
are going to use
to find a solution to this problem that
is
to display the total number of products
in each category
so first let me give my comment to
display the total number of products in
each category i'll just write print
total
products
okay
so
to solve this problem we are going to
use our two tables
so let me first display the rows and
columns from both the tables the first
table is products
okay it is products
let's run this and see the columns that
we have in this table
okay so you have the product id which is
the primary key you have the product
name so there are total
77 different products okay
and then you have the supplier id you
have the category id so these two
columns are the foreign key columns you
have the quantity per unit unit price
units in stock units in order
and if you want to reorder
some product to fill in the stocks so
you have information for that as well
and if the product has been discontinued
or not
i'll copy this and let's see what
rows and columns we have
in my categories table
okay
let me execute this
okay
so we have total eight categories of
products you can see beverages we have
dairy products
meat or poultry you have produce seafood
these are the description
[Music]
okay
now to find the total number of products
in each category
i'll write my query as
select i'll write
category
name
comma
count star
i'll give this an alias name as total
products
given underscore and write products
from
my first table that is
products
given alias as p i am going to use an
inner join
with
my categories table
and i will give my alias as c
on my common key column that is p dot
category id
is equal to
c dot
category id
then
i'm going to
group my results
based on the category
names so i'll write category
name
and we'll use the
order by clause i'll write order by
count star
as
descending
so let's see the total number of
products that we have in each category
so this shouldn't be as descending
should be just count star descending
okay i'll select and run it
there you go
so here on the left hand side you have
the different category names and
on the right you have the
total number of
products that belong to each of the
categories
all right
now moving on to the final question
so the last question is to use the
northwind database
and using this database we want to find
the list of late orders for all the
employees
so this is a real world problem that
often occurs
so the shipment of your orders might get
delayed due to logistic issues or if the
products are not available on time there
can be various other reasons as well so
here we want to find those orders for
the employees
or where the required date is less than
the shipment date
we are going to use two different tables
that is orders and employees
okay now let me give my comment for the
final
query that we are going to write in this
interview questions tutorial
so using the orders table i want to find
the list of orders for all the employees
so i'll just give list
of
late orders not just orders for
employees i write emp
s
which stands for employees
so here
i'm going to use two tables orders and
employees
orders table we have already seen let's
see the rows and columns that are
present in the employees table i'll
write select star from employees
and let me run it
okay so there are total nine employees
we have
so we have the employee id this is the
primary key column which goes from one
to nine we have the last name of the
employee the first name of the employee
we have the title
then we have the
title of courtesy but the doctor
mr missus
we have the birth day of the employee
the higher date or the date of join
you have the address city region postal
code and other information
all right
so let's
see how you can join the orders table
and the employees table to get the
list of late orders and we must remember
that late orders are those
where the required date is less than
equal to the shipped date
so i'll start with select
e dot
i'll write employee id
comma
i want the
first name
comma
i'm going to count
star as
late orders
from
my table orders as o
then i'll use my inner join
i'll write
employees
as
e
it doesn't matter actually if you use
small e or capital e
then i am going to use my on condition
on e dot
on
e dot
employee id
equal to
o dot employee id
so this is my common key column that is
present in both the tables
then i'll use my where clause where
you should be careful
and you should keep the right clause so
my required date
should be less than or equal to my
shift date
so this is my condition
and then i am going to group by
e dot employee id
comma
e dot
first name
and then i'll use my order by clause
order by
my alias name that was late orders
and i'll arrange it in descending order
so let's run this and see our result
okay so
you have the employee ids on the left
then you have the first name of the
employee ids and then you have the late
orders for each of these employees so if
you see here employee id 4 has the
highest number of late orders followed
by employee id
3 and 8
as well as 9 who have 5 late orders then
we have the employee id two which has
four late orders even employed is seven
has four lead orders employee id five
that is steven has only one late orders
so we are done with our
demo section and we have covered all our
30 questions out of which 25 questions
were based and used on mysql server
and to address the last five questions
we used our northwind database that had
a lot of tables you can see it here and
using those tables we solve some
interesting questions
okay so that brings us to the end of
this video tutorial on sql interview
questions i hope this was useful and
informative if you want to
get the sql code file that we have used
in this demo then please feel free to
put your email ids in the comments
section thank you for watching and keep
learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
and so with that we come to the end of
this session on web developer interview
questions if you have any doubts or
queries let us know in the comment
section below we'll be happy to help you
watch out for more videos from us until
then keep learning and stay tuned to
simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here